have you ever fallen down the YouTube
rabbit hole of like those [__] pimple
popping videos bro I can't watch those
guys
I don't understand I'm calling out
people who enjoy watching videos
oh she's left okay so no offense for
people who love watching videos like
that what the [__] is wrong with you
it's so gross I don't understand like
people say like it's satisfying and I'm
like slime videos are satisfying just
watch those no I do get it because when
you pop when I pop my own pimple or
something yeah it is kind of satisfying
yeah really when you pop your own pimple
and you get all that [__] out of it it
just hurts no it doesn't hurt it does no
I used to have mad acne on my face when
I was in high school and so like I would
sometimes accidentally pop pimples just
by like scrunching my face
I had really bad acne no dude because
when you get a bunch out you're like
[__] a nice together yeah but then it
just leaves a [__] scar on your face
you know for long though oh sometimes
it's permanent oh really yeah yeah
that's why you shouldn't pop your pizza
yeah I I actually like I actually have
some permanent scars on my face because
of it I can't tell you but it's I have
the beard to hide it but it's super
[__] hard to not pop it because it's
just so satisfying yeah dermatologists
always say like don't pause oh you're
not supposed to no you're not supposed
to because it leaves a mark because
sometimes you can actually like push it
like even like more deeply in yeah if
you pop it like Incorrect and then when
that thing eventually pops whether you
like it or not then it [__] hurts and
it can stop bleeding yeah yeah and
that's the satisfying ones though that's
that's all you know everything else but
okay but like even
okay I get it like popping your own
pimple satisfying right because it gets
rid of this thing on your face popping
other people's pimples too yeah yeah but
like I don't want to see a rainbow
person's pimple getting popped super
[__] up close and where you can see
all the [__] pus and like [__] coming
out of it I'm like that's just gross I
don't want to see that do you think
you'd take care of yourself if you as
much if you want a YouTuber how much
less would you take care of yourself if
you went on camera uh well I can show
you a picture when I was in high school
and uh it's pretty bad yeah I feel like
I would have been the biggest [__]
Slob on earth oh 100 I would be like 300
pounds like I just wouldn't care yeah
yeah I feel like I take care of myself
the same I don't know I would not I
would not you YouTube like the only the
only thing that I've done because of
YouTube is kind of like when I was like
you know put on makeup but that was just
like I would I would have probably done
that eventually just because I would
just have been searching for a way just
to stop these [__] comments like
every time I see someone yeah
um I mean it is frustrating especially
like if uh same with like if for some
reason someone sees like a part of my
like a balding area yeah every comment
is like oh my God even though it's
saying I've spoke about like a million
times yeah and it's one of those things
and unfortunately it's just like it is
what it is yeah yeah and lighting
especially Studio lighting which is very
bright and my skin tone reflects so it's
like oh [__] yeah and it's just one of
those things where it's like I don't
care about this nearly as much as the
comments do yeah but seeing all those
comments is like dude could you talk
about the goddamn video yeah exactly
yeah no exactly get that I get that
that's the thing and I would never have
cared about like finding ways to kind of
like you know uh make it better yeah
until uh all these [__] comments were
like hey you should do you know why why
the [__] you balding yeah bro what do
you mean why yeah it's it's not like
like you have a choice like there's some
people who post on like Reddit like oh
my God Conor's balding yeah it's like
what do you mean like yes who cares I
had British genetics I was [__] from
the start yeah I mean it's yeah it's not
like I wake up every day I'm like oh my
God
sometimes just like a slight annoyance
um and I'm like yo can we talk about the
thing that we want that I want to talk
about and it's you know it was just like
an easy way just to like couple comments
yeah but like even if like I didn't have
YouTube I don't know I feel like I've
never
I've never put too much effort into like
self-grooming but I've never been like
full of full-blown degenerates closet I
feel like I would be a totally different
person if I just didn't somehow end up
doing these YouTube YouTube videos
because I didn't I didn't really care
about taking care of myself in any
capacity right like I was like I'll just
do video games I would I would the only
reason I would take care of myself
without the YouTube videos is like for
my partner yeah right like if my partner
is like oh you're kind of [__] fat
then I'll be like all right well you
know what maybe best to start getting in
shape yeah you know that honestly that's
that's kind of like the best motivation
you know I I want to stay looking good
yeah for my wife yeah I want to say
looking good exactly like sometimes I'm
like yo Sydney do you wanted me to get
like bigger muscles and like get a
six-pack and she's like no and I'm like
part of me is just like this but what if
like what if I could yo yo how much how
much would that make her happy if I did
even though she said she doesn't want to
see it I'm like maybe maybe one day I'm
gonna wake up and I'm gonna I'm gonna
commit twice all your great food and
drink to get a six-pack because I'm not
no
will compare to a great beer
I don't think like the reason I said Six
Flags because I don't think it would
take me too much work to get a six-pack
just because I'm so thin yeah as it is
that like I've you know when when I went
to the gym more regularly before I was
like actually like I think quite close
to getting a six-pack because it was
like starting to show just because I
didn't have to lose too much weight for
the muscle to start showing
um so that's why I'm just like maybe
maybe one so that's why I was so glad
when I I also asked the same question
Arc I was like would you like it if I
was like more toned and like you know
six-pack maybe not a six-pack but just
like more muscly tone and she's like no
I like it the way you are and I was just
like oh thank God
all right
woman hand me my pizza
whatever makes you happy right yeah yeah
but of course she's gonna say that now
of course of course of course your
partner's gonna be like no honey I love
you just the way you are but if
hypothetically she said I would like to
see you in a six-pack I would probably
try and do my best to give myself a
six-pack fair enough you know because
it's like if that's what makes her happy
then that's what will make me happy
right I'd be like damn you're in the
right in the wrong relationships
I found it very um
so the the most common
um if you ever try to you know you take
uh like Rogaine or whatever any hair
medication like the main one the one
that's like the only one that's like FDA
approved whatever yeah yeah all the ads
that you you hear on YouTube and stuff
all promote whatever yeah um I just
found it so [__] funny that the one
side effect this drug so you can they're
like you can stop losing your hair yeah
okay yeah like there was a side effect
there and you're like go on it's like
there is a chance you may be impotent
and you're like wow what a cruel
trade-off you can still you can feel and
look more attractive and have your hair
but you're rolling the dice as if your
dick will work and you're like God damn
dude that's the site like it could have
been anything it could have been like
depression weight gain any of those
things
it's like it's like it's like they you
it's like a movie plot you couldn't
design this side effect more perfect for
what they're called like yeah like you
know that's the equivalent of being like
you can have the sexiest six-pack to get
anyone that you want but you have to get
a vasectomy yeah yeah yeah but no way no
that does that I don't think that would
be as much of it you certainly still
have the dick jokes
yeah but yeah because I I remember
because uh I was I I had this
conversation with uh didus like yeah uh
before as well because uh I told him
that uh I I was also taking uh yeah he
seemed to believe that it would just you
no matter what if you took it your PP
don't work I told him I'm like no no no
so if if you do research I believe there
is uh one percent job it's small it's
it's a very very small charts I believe
is one percent uh that you'll just get
impotency no maybe not since when you
you feel it's not I was it's like you're
way less you have like way less desire
for sexual activity and you could could
your people might not work as much yeah
yeah in that in that department so what
if that matters to you yes so so yeah I
I told artists that yeah I take this as
well the first thing he says yeah the
same [__] thing to me yeah the first
thing he says to me is yo did you win
the gotcha and I was like so what what
do you mean what do you mean and he goes
the dick gotcha did you win and I was
just like oh wait yeah maybe okay I had
the conversation with him where I was
like he was like yeah I don't know if I
should start taking it and I was like
well I wish I did research sooner
because like it completely pretty much
stopped any kind of yeah aggressive hair
loss like it's so it's like kind of it's
just normal now yeah it's not normal but
like it doesn't get worse and it got a
little bit better yeah um and so I was
like dude if you're even thinking about
might happen you may as well just
[__] if you're worried about it just
start now before you actually are
balding and then yeah or your hairline
recedes and you're like oh well because
there's no way there's no way to regrow
hair that's lost without getting a
[__] transplant or something uh the
only way that you can stop yourself uh
stop you from losing hair is prevention
so you need to get there before I know
this sounds like an ad yeah we literally
like literally okay this is literally
like the keeps ad read but that's
because it's like I I did my research
even before getting or you could just I
used to think it was so cringe All Those
ads that were promoting it now that's
[__] stupid now I'm like God damn I
wish I [__] started
because you know you I think you always
think and I I was very guilty of this as
well like yeah because you just when
you're growing up and you have hair for
[__] 20 years you just always think
oh this is never gonna happen to me yeah
yeah you you always think that and then
like maybe you notice one day I think
yeah do you remember the first time you
noticed yes how did you how I mean do
you feel comfortable sharing yeah yeah I
mean like I I mean I I believe I've told
you this in private but uh I knew I was
gonna vote basically uh every one on my
dad's side uh was is just bold and has
you know even if they haven't completely
lost it on on the top of it yes uh
they've all lost their head it's
something tell them sooner why don't we
know sooner yeah so I remember because
you know I I
this was back in like the Sasuke hair
phase right right I my favorite thing I
like my hair okay and not not that not
that you know I don't think I could pull
off like a bold thing I just don't I
just don't know if um it's I don't I
just don't know if I'm ready for it to
be like my identity I mean no you know
what I mean you've had the benefits
of that phase I know I can pull it off
but you know I'd like it to be instead
of be like a choice I'd like it to be a
choice rather than a choice that's
thrust upon me right right yeah uh so I
remember when I was like you know 17 18.
I was like Dad uh everyone on your side
of the family is bold and I remember
like what started this conversation was
I remember seeing a picture of my dad uh
when he was like you know in his like
20s uh and he he had he had a lot of
hair yeah he had hair down to [__]
here he's had he had more hair yeah yeah
he's had more hair than I ever did in my
life and I was just like oh Dad you used
to have a lot of hair he's like yep yeah
thanks for bringing it off and I was
like uh so like out of curiosity when
did you start losing it and he was like
oh my God I don't remember I think it
was like around like 30 or something
yeah I've never been nice I've I've
never forgotten this conversation in my
life because I remember I this this
conversation is engraved in my mind
because as soon as I heard that as soon
as I hit 25 I was like start taking
pictures I started I started taking
pictures and it's it is literally you
going through the five stale the five
stages of denial yeah you do right
because like I must have just I must
have just part of it yeah it's just been
laid out yeah my hair doesn't go on this
side yeah yeah everyone has a little dog
so like I started regularly taking
pictures of like my scalp uh since I was
around the age of like 25 26 and I was
like I've been the genetics 25 years old
I pulled the gotcha yeah yeah at age 26.
my dad's talking [__] I have a full head
of hair baby 27. oh maybe that's maybe
that's a bad angle is that a bad angle
that might just be a bad angle I still
look good baby age 28 nah I mean like
that's that's like a normal hairline
that's you know everyone who gets old
has like a little bit of like a little
bit of receding uh recession there I
forgot what it was called huh
that's just the Widow speak that's just
the widow's peak age 29. uh this is when
I've like fully moved to Japan for like
you know uh like the first year yeah I
was like
but it could be it could be uh like I'm
I'm you know what you know what you know
this is this I know this looks like a
bad picture I know this looks like a bad
picture but maybe maybe it's just uh
maybe it's just a bad picture bad
lighting bad lighting and uh can I get a
new phone yeah yeah yeah and it was when
like it was when I hit like the age of
like 30. I just had like there was like
one awful picture and there was like one
video where I believe like the back of
my head was showing up I think it was
might have been like the drifting
special or something and I'm like I'm
like okay acceptance time yeah I am I am
losing my hair but it still doesn't look
super it does it doesn't look too bad so
that's when I started doing like a lot
of research into this
um and ever since I started taking uh
started taking the pill
um it's not gonna it's not gotten any
worse it's gotten like slightly better
nowhere near as good yeah as when I
started tracking it when I was like 20
25 or whatever but it's not good and any
worse you know which is which is a good
thing which is a good thing yeah yeah
yeah it's very strange I did I ever tell
you the story about how I I asked my dad
how he lost his hair no I was like I was
like Dad how did you uh because you had
to hit like a giant bold area and I was
like how did you how did that happen
he's straight up [__] lied
you lied to me I escaped from a house
fire and he said that like while he was
working something dropped on his head
and that ever since then he hasn't been
able to grow hair there and it's a
[__] kid I just believe him and so
going into my adulthood I just had that
in the back of my mind I didn't think
about it and then now I realize the
[__] lied to him why would you
not just tell his kid that hey I you
bald sometimes you just lose it yeah
because what the [__] in my family's
case I wasn't even the one that brought
up the question my parents used to just
[__] give me [__] about it being like
[__] you're gonna get a bowl
yeah you're like what the hell because
like my granddad went like started like
actually getting like a full patch here
at like 26 22 yeah I mean and he was
like it sucks to be you Joey that's
gonna happen to you and I'm just
[__] my pants like you know all
throughout High School I feel like
that's the right way to go about it yeah
because I feel like I I wish I was like
talked about to me more yeah it could be
a thing that could happen that hey if
you want to do something about it yeah
one thing I've realized one thing I've
realized right
especially especially in this case the
only reason the only reason I was like I
was super attentive about like my my
hairline and whether I was going bold or
not uh because swear to [__]
God every time I'd ask a loved one if I
if I looked any worse they'd they'd just
be like no you're not boating don't
worry about it honey whether it's like
[__] Sydney or my mum my mum my mum
full-on Asian [__] mum being like
honey you're not gonna Bowl don't worry
about it it's just it's just in your
head and it was only when I showed her
pictures of when I turned 30 that she
actually just like yes and I was like
Mom this is my hairline right now yo you
want to go back on your word because if
I weren't taking pictures this is where
I'd be right now Mom yeah I mean to be
honest like if I ever see like a little
like you know you see a little bit of a
hat like someone's head through the hair
you're like oh well it's not you know
you don't think of it as like a bald
spot just like I could just see that
scalp yeah but I guess when it gets
bigger is when it's you know there's a
very thin line between when it looks
like you're balding and when it's just
like a yeah yeah
um but you know you keep track and then
you notice I remember one time
oh my God I spent like 21. and I just
was like huh just saw something in the
mirror because I somehow saw the back of
my head and I was like that's
feels like my hair has been done
differently yeah it definitely wasn't
there when I checked a few months ago
and I was like no I can't pull them like
21. this wouldn't happen but yeah sure
enough it was yeah and it wasn't getting
any worse for a while and then it
suddenly just got started getting a lot
worse and I was like oh [__] I gotta do
something about this yeah uh oh I gotta
just shave it all off yeah which I'm
happy to do but I'm like man it'd be a
nice time for a few more years